por aquí tenemos la gráfica de la gtx y
esta vez lo que queremos hacer es
encontrar el límite de gtx cuando x
tiende a 6 por la izquierda a 6 menos
por la dirección negativa así que esto
va a ser igual y bueno si tienes una
pequeña idea del resultado intenta
obtenerlo por tu cuenta y pausa
inmediatamente este vídeo
para resolver este límite vamos a
fijarnos en algunos valores de x que se
aproximen a 6 por la izquierda y vamos a
ver qué evaluación obtenemos de estos
valores en la función g
así que pensemos a 72 bueno observa que
g de 2 es un poquito más que 1 que de 3
es un poquito más que g de 274 es un
poquito abajo de 275 está alrededor de
37 5.5 este está cercano a 57 5.75
parece ser 9 y así que observan que
mientras más nos acercamos a 6 por la
izquierda parece que los valores de la
función empiezan a hacer no a cuota 2
van convirtiéndose en valores más y más
y más grandes hasta volverse
infinitamente grandes es por eso que en
este contexto algunas personas ponen
como resultado igual a infinito pero el
infinito como tal no es un número
específico
así que si estamos hablando en un
sentido técnico sobre un límite algunas
veces se pone justo como infinito pero
en un sentido más estricto
en varios de los ejercicios de lacan
academy encontrarás como una mejor
respuesta que este límite no existe
dicho en otras palabras este límite que
buscamos no está acotado y ahora observa
que esto es muy interesante porque en
este caso aunque el límite por la
izquierda no existe por otra parte el
límite por la derecha si vamos a buscar
cuál es el límite dgt x cuando x tienden
a 6 por la derecha por valores mayores
que 6 y esto es igual y vamos a observar
de nuevo la gráfica si vemos que de 8
está por aquí que de 7 va por a camps g
de 6.5 es un poquito menor que menos 3
que de 6.1 está aún más cerca de menos
37 6.001 aún más más cerca de menos
37.000 0 0001 está muy pero muy pero muy
cerca de menos 3 así que el límite de gd
x cuando x tiende a 6 por la derecha va
a ser igual a menos 3 porque el valor al
cual nos aproximamos por valores mayores
que 6
por la derecha de 6 es el valor de menos
3 pero no olvides por el lado izquierdo
tenemos una función no acortada y por lo
tanto diremos que este límite no existe
y esa es mi respuesta